bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour suivre dans un
instant la remise du rapport annuel de
la Cour des comptes c'était jeudi dans
l'hémicycle finances publiqu fraude
fiscale centrale nucléaire ou encore
lutte contre le tabagisme comme chaque
année la Cour des comptes a remis ses
bons et ses mauvais points parmi les
mauvais points noté également l'échec du
contrat de génération 500000 contrats
étai promis par François Hollande d'ici
2017 et bien seulement 40000 ont été
conclus l'été dernier ce dispositif est
jugé peu lisible trop complexe par les
entreprise en revanche au niveau global
des finances publiques il y a du mieux
la situation s'améliore selon Didier
Guillaume le premier président de la
Cour des comptes mais cela est si lent
et si fragile que cela reste source de
préoccupation voire d'inquiétude tout de
suite donc retour à la remise de ce
rapport c'était jeudi dernier dans
l'hémicycle mes chers collègues nous
vons d'apprendre une nouvelle terrible
six personnes ce matin ont été tuées
dans un accident entre un minibus
scolaire et un poids lourd à Rochefort
en charrante maritime hier il y a eu la
mort de deux adolescents dans le dou là
aussi dans un quart scolaire je voulais
simplement vous dire qu'au nom du Sénat
tout entier j'adresserai aux victimes à
leurs famille à leurs proches les
sincères condoléances de notre assemblée
je suis certain vous vous associerez par
la pensée euh à ce que ces familles mais
aussi la communauté
scolaire est en train de
vivre l'ordre du jour appelle le dépôt
du rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes
et je vais demander à nos uissers de
faire
entrer le premier président et procureur
général de la Cour des comptes
rapporteur
général monsieur le Premier Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général c'est
avec un grand plaisir que nous vous
accueillons ce matin pour la
présentation du rapport velle de la Cour
des comptes je voudrais dire que les
liens à la fois anciens et étroit entre
le Sénat et la Cour des comptes ont été
renforcés par la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 qui a consacré
la mission d'assistance de la cour au
Parlement et je dois dire au nom de tous
mes collègues au nom des présidents de
commission
euh combien nous nous félicitons de
pouvoir bénéficier de votre expertise
pour exercer les missions de contrôle et
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
qui sont les nôre d'ailleurs la
Conférence des Présidents hier soir avec
les présidents de délégation et les
présidents de commission examiner cette
mission de contrôle qui est très
importante notamment au Sénat et qui
s'inscrit génétiquement dans les mission
du Sénat je connais monsieur le Premier
Président Monsieur rapport a toute
l'attention que vous portez au Parlement
nous connaissons votre attachement à
répondre à nos préoccupations et
monsieur le Premier Président je me
réjouit des relations que que nous
entretenons je crois que jamais
l'intensité des relations entre nos deux
institutions n'aura été si forte vous
êtes très régulièrement sollicité par
nos commissions permanentes et par nos
délégations c'est bien sûr la commission
des finances 55 opérations de contrôle
je le rappelle je l'ai bien en tête hier
soir Madame la Présidente et la
commission des affaires sociales et le
Président hier soir aussi nous nous en
rendait compte au cours de l'année 2015
la commission des finances a bénéficier
notamment de l'éclairage de la cour sur
des sujets aussi variés que le Crédit
Immobilier de France des aides
personnelles logement les enjeux les
leviers de la maîtrise de la masse
salariale de l'État le bilan de
l'autonomie financière des universités
ou encore le l'ensemble des soutiens à
la filière forêt bois les rapport que
vous avez établi à la demande de la
commission des affaires sociales
notamment sur la situation des
maternités a donneré lieu ici à un riche
débat en hémicycle les autres instances
sénatoriales sollicitent également la
cour dans le cadre de leurs travaux de
contrôle et leurs travaux
législatifs par exemple monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Président
ident vous avez été entendu par notre
commission des lois dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi portant
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
République les magistrats ont été
auditionnés par la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable à la suite du
rapport public thématique
notamment sur la grande vitesse
ferroviaire la délégation au
collectivité territoriale à bénéficié de
l'éclairage de votre juridiction sur les
finances notamment des communes toutes
ces sollicitations illustrent
l'attention que le Sénat porte à vos
observations constat et
recommandations formulé par vous-même et
naturellement auensite qui leur sont
réservé la remise du rapport annuel de
la Cour des Comptes est attendue à un
moment la situation de nos finances
publiques demeure une réelle et
insistante
préoccupation les circonstances que nous
vivons on rappelé la nécessité de
disposer de tous les moyens pour
affronter et répondre aux menaces qui
nous entourent nous devons chacun le
sait accélérer la réduction des déficits
qui aliment la dette à l'excès et à une
capacité à agir souverainement et à
engager un certain nombre de réformes
pour créer la croissance dans notre pays
à besoin c'est donc avec le plus grand
intérêt monsieur le Premier Président
que nous allons à présent vous écouter
présenter le rapport annuel de la Cour
des comptes madame la présidente de la
commission des finances et monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales inter interviendront ensuite
monsieur le Premier
Président je vous invite à prendre la
parole à notre
tribune merci
beaucoup
vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des finances
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires sociales mesdames et
messieurs les
sénateurs la présentation du rapport
public annuel que je viens de remettre à
votre président en application de
l'article L 1436 du Code des
juridictions financières est un moment
important pour les juridictions
financières et nous en sommes convaincus
pour le débat autour de la bonne gestion
publique or ce rapport n'est pas loin
sans faux une collection d'anecdotes ni
un florilège d'observation
circonstantielle il est guidé structuré
par une préoccupation centrale formuler
des pistes de réforme contribuer à la
modernisation des services publics en
expliquant ce qui fonctionne bien ce qui
pourrait progresser et
encourager les décideurs à s'intéresser
davantage aux résultats de l'action
publique les messages portés par le
rapport de la Cour sont au nombre de
trois la situation des finances
publiques s'améliore mais cette
amélioration est encore lente limitée
fragile la situation reste en
conséquence source de préup upation voir
d'inquiétude deuxièmement l'urgence de
moderniser les services publics appelle
des choix déterminés et une mise en
œuvre méthodique troisièmement et enfin
nos contrôles mettent en
évidence la nécessité d'une plus grande
clarté d'une plus grande sélectivité
d'une plus grande efficacité d'une plus
grande efficience de l'action publique
pour répondre aux attentes de nos
concitoyens mais également aux objectifs
que vous définissez avant d'entrer dans
le le détail de ces messages je veux
consacrer un court propos liminaire à la
manière dont la cour et les Chambres
régionales et territoriales s'efforcent
de contribuer par leur action à
l'amélioration de la gestion publique
j'insiste tout d'abord sur l'unité la
cohérence du rapport public annuel le
premier tome s'intéresse à la situation
d'ensemble des finances publiques au vu
des dernières données disponibles ainsi
qu'à plusieurs politique publique et à
différentes problématiques de gestion
publique il fournit des exemples de
réformes que les pouvoirs publics
pourraient choisir de conduire le second
t met sur la table le bilan de
l'activité de la cour et des chambres
régionales ainsi que les suites
données par les pouvoirs publics à leurs
recommandation les codes couleur de ce
des chapitres de ce second tome sont
désormais bien connus la Cour constate
des progrès là la couleur est verte la
cour insiste la couleur est orange la
cour alerte et là c'est le rouge
certains progrès sont très directement
liés aux recommandations que la Cour a
pu formuler dans le passé reprise par
les pouvoirs publics je pense en premier
lieu à la politique française
d'incorporation des biocarburants dans
les carburants vous avez récemment
procédé à des ajustements utiles
conformément à nos recommandations comme
la fin de mesures de
défiscalisation incohérente ou
l'inclusion du gazol non routier dans
l'assiette de l'attaque générale sur les
activités
polluantes je pense en deuxième lieu au
financement de la défense
national par des ressources
exceptionnelles malgré les risques
identifiés par la Cour vous avez
souhaité dans la loi de programmation
militaire substitué des crédits
budgétaires à la quasi-ttalité des
ressources exceptionnelles cette
clarification bienvenue a été mise en
œuvre dans la loi de finances pour 2016
elle doit maintenant être confirmée dans
le temps et mené à son
terme le troisième exemple bien connu
concerne la gestion de l'extinction de
Dexia le gouvernement a déposé un
amendement au projet de loi sur la
déontologie des fonctionnaires
directement inspiré de de nos travaux
que vous avez bien voulu voter au Sénat
qui porte sur ce que l'on appelle les
parachutes dorées un fonctionnaire ayant
exercer des fonctions de dirigeant dans
un organisme public ou bénéficiant de
concours public ne pourra plus
réintégrer son administration d'origine
et percevoir en même temps de cet
organisme des indemnités liées à la
cessation de ses fonctions cette
avancée ne vaut bien sûr pas seulement
en cas de sinistre et doit encore être
confirmé dans le texte qui sera adopté
définitivement dans son rapport publ
2016 la cour fait le point sur
l'exercice de ses compétences notamment
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président l'évaluation des politique
publique nous avons répondu à un certain
nombre de demandes émanant de
l'Assemblée nationale mais aussi du
Sénat et j'en profite monsieur le
Président pour me réjouir de la qualité
des relations entre la cour et le
Parlement qui témoigne de l'intensité et
de la portée de la mission d'assistance
de la juridiction à la représentation
nationale bien sûr je pense tout
particulièrement à la qualité des
relations entre les commissions des
finances et des affaires social du Sénat
et la Cour des
comptes j'en viens au premier message de
la cour la situation des finances
publiques s'améliore mais cette
amélioration est encore lente limitée
fragile et la situation reste en
conséquence source de préoccupation
voire d'inquiétude la Cour relève la
difficulté rencontré pour redresser
cette situation plus nettement et plus
durablement malgré les efforts
entrepris selon les dernières prévision
du gouvernement les objectifs de
réduction des déficits publics auraient
été tenus l'année dernière les résultats
devraient être même être meilleurs que
prévu pour autant cette baisse est resté
lente et limitée la prévision
gouvernementale de maîtrise des déficits
pour 2016 est plus ambitieuse qu'en 2015
la réalisation de cet objectif
reste encore malgré tout incertaine pour
trois raisons d'une part les hypothèses
d'inflation et de hausse de la masse
salariale du secteur privé donc les
prévisions de recettes fisc et sociales
paraissent surestimer les prévisions
toutes récentes de la Commission
européenne viennent d'ailleurs de
confirmer ce risque d'autre part le
choix de sous-dotter dans la
programmation budgétaire initiale
certaines dépenses de l'État fait peser
des risques de dépassement des urgences
prévisibles en cours d'année comme le
plan pour l'emploi et la formation
annoncé par le gouvernement ces
dernières semaines sont susceptibles
d'accentuer ces risques enfin l'objectif
retenu pour la croissance des dépenses
sociales sera également difficile à
tenir une partie des économies attendues
en matière de régime complément de
retraite complémentaire et d'assurance
chômage pourrait ne pas être au
rendez-vous cette année la cour se
réjouit évidemment de la perspective
d'un retour à des conditions économiques
un peu plus favorables mais la prudence
reste de mise en 2016 le déficit public
devrait rester supérieur à tris points
de PIB la dette publique approcherait
100 points de PIB et cette situation
n'autorise aucun relâchement des efforts
la réduction des déficits publics ne
peut en effet pas seulement reposer sur
l'amélioration des recettes permises par
une amélioration conjoncturelle elle
doit aussi résulter d'une action résolue
sur le besoin de financement structurel
de toutes les administrations publiques
état collectivité territoriale sécurité
sociale et dans ce dernier cas nous ne
pouvons collectivement je crois pas nous
satisfaire d'un déficit durable des
comptes sociaux destiné uniquement à
financer des dépenses courantes or une
fois de plus la question n'est pas pour
la cour des compte de tenir une position
dogmatique ni de recommander à toute
force de réduire les crédits nécessaires
à l'exercice de mission prioritaire la
question qui se pose est celle de
l'efficacité de l'efficience de la
dépense publique et de la pertinence de
crédit àoué à des missions des
structures dont l'utilité n'est plus
aussi démontrée il faut mettre en regard
les moyens consacrés et les résultats
effectivement obtenus avant de décider
d'un éventuel maintien voire d'un
abondement de ces moyens l'augmentation
des dépenses ne doit pas être la
principale voire la seule réponse à
chaque fois qu'un problème est identifié
au risque de perdre de vue l'exigence
d'efficacité et d'efficience de l'action
publique au total la maîtrise des
déficits et du poids de la dette
publique doit être poursuivie avec
vigueur dans le cas contraire la France
risquerait d'être à l'avenir encore plus
contrainte dans l'utilisation de
l'instrument budgétaire il y a un mois
lors de l'audience solennelle de la Cour
j'évoqué la capacité de la France à
procéder à des choix souverains de
politique publicque sa capacité à
dégager des marges de manœuvre pour
faire face aux priorités du
temps il faut reconnaître que cette
capacité reste entravé par la
situation des finances publiques
plusieurs insertions de ce rapport
annuel 2016 illustrent parfaitement la
difficulté parfois
rencontrée dans la répartition des
moyens consacrés à des missions
régaliennes c'est notamment le cas du
contrôle de l'égalité et du contrôle
budgétaire des actes des collectivités
territoriales notre rapport démontre que
sans modernisation de l'organisation et
des modes de fonctionnement la réduction
uniforme des moyens est inefficace
plus grave encore elle peut fragiliser
voir remettre en cause l'exercice de
certaines missions pourtant
essentiel j'en arrive au deuxème message
de la cour qui est le fil rouge du
rapport l'urgence de moderniser les
servic public appelle des choix
déterminés et mise en œuvre méthodique
cette méthode repose sur des principe de
bon sens une réforme réussie repose sur
une bonne anticipation des besoins une
ification correcte des investissements
pertinents une conduite rigoureuse et un
accompagnement du changement selon le
calendrier approprié
c'est-à-dire sans précipitation mais
également sans immobilisme le cas des
transports ferroviaires en île-de-fance
et celui de la politique de maintenance
des centrales nucléaires illustre tout à
fait la nécessité pour les pouvoirs
publics de choisir avec rigueur et de
hiérarchiser les investissements à
consentir dans la durée par
ailleurs je
suis souvent amené au nom des
juridictions financières évoquer la
question de la pertinence des dépenses
d'investissement contrairement à une
idée reçue elles ne sont pas vertueuses
par principe l'investissement est
vertueux quand il répond à un besoin
collectif lorsqu'il est produit avec le
souci de l'efficacité et de l'efficience
et dès lors que les dépenses de
fonctionnement qu' entreelles ont été
correctement anticipé or le rapport
public 2016
offre de nouvelles illustrations
d'investissement dont la pertinence
n'est pas
démontrée vous l'avez compris une
mauvaise idée fait le plus souvent une
mauvaise réforme mais une idée qui n'est
pas mauvaise en soi ne fait pas
nécessairement une bonne réforme la cour
analyse ainsi les raisons de l'échec du
contrat de génération il pouvait s'agir
d'une bonne idée mais la multiplication
des objectifs poursuivis la complexité
du dispositif finalement adopté lui ont
portter préjudice les entreprises l'ont
perçu comme une contrainte
supplémentaire et ne l'ont pas vraiment
adopté par rapport à une attente de
220000 contrats de génération en juillet
2015 il y en a seulement
4300 la fusion entre Transdev et volia
transport constitue autre opération mal
conçu son bilan est très négatif à court
terme pour la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation dont le choix stratégique
devra bien sûr être apprécié sur le long
terme les juridictions financières sont
conduite dans leurs travaux à étudier la
capacité des gestionnaires publics à
mener les projets ambitieux décidés
jusqu'au bout de la logique qui les sent
le cas du versement de la
solde des militaires
est illustratif de la difficulté parfois
rencontrée pour mener une réforme à son
terme surtout lorsqu'elle passe par le
refondte d'un système
d'information l'exemple des
facteurs dont la profession est
confrontée à la baisse du volume de
courrier ou de l'archéologie préventive
appelle à aller plus loin dans l'effort
de modernisation et
d'adaptation autre enseignement de nos
contrôles une réforme une fois décidée
gagne à être menée rapidement et
résolument d'un beau calendrier d'un bon
rythme le résultat est souvent éloigné
de l'objectif fixé et plus
coûteux lorsque des réformes ont été
engagé leur conduite suppose que le cap
soit maintenu c'est notamment le cas de
la réforme des organismes payeurs des
aides agricoles caractérisé par des
retard la réforme de l'inspection du
travail montre par défaut l'utilité des
réflexes de bon sens que je viens
d'énumérer il est sans doute regrettable
que ce service est connu depuis 10 ans
des réformes successives dont les
finalités n'ont été que progressivement
définies le climat de travail les
résultats n'ont été affectés la cour
recommande que cette modernisation soit
désormais mené à son terme
rapidement nos contrôles mettent en
évidence la nécessité d'une plus grande
clarté d'une plus grande sélectivité
d'une plus grande efficacité d'une plus
grande efficience de l'action publique
pour
répondre à la fois aux attentes des
concitoyens mais aussi aux objectifs que
vous définissez vous-même et c'est notre
3oisème et dernier
message pour répondre à ces attentes les
pouvoirs publics doivent envisager la
suppression des structures qui ne
démontrent plus leur utilité clarifier
les orientations des politiques
publiques qui lancent et s'y tenir
susciter enfin un sursaut de
responsabilité individuelle et
collective deux structures publiques
font l'objet d'une analyse dans le
rapport annuel 2016 pour conclure à la
nécessité de programmer très rapidement
leur
extinction le premier est l'Institut
français du cheval et de l'équitation le
second est le fond de solidarité dont
les missions de collègu pourrai être
confié à un réseau de recouvrement tel
que celui de la Direction générale des
finances publiques ou de la cause qu'il
n'y ait pas de malentendu nous ne
proposons pas de supprimer les
prestations de solidarité mais ce fond
de solidarité qui est en fait un
organisme de collecte dont lesémission
pourrai tout à fait être assuré par
d'autres organismes de collecte qui
existent plusieurs politiques publiques
pâtissent par ailleurs du manque de
clarté des orientations retenues voir de
la difficulté à s'y tenir le rapport
évoque les théâtres nationaux ou encore
la politique de la ville la cour revient
aussi sur le Centre national de la
fonction publique territoriale le CNFPT
fonctionne comme un établissement public
sans tutelle vous pourriez être fondé à
adapter le niveau de ses ressources en
fonction de son activité et des
conditions de leur emploi en ce sens la
baisse du plafond de la cotisation que
vous avez incluse dans la loi de
finances pour 2016 est une initation
forte
pour améliorer son efficience égard au
Marg de manœuvre dont il dispose en tout
cas c'est notre
sentiment l'esprit de réforme que les
citoyens attendent des gestionnaires
publics suppose un esprit de
responsabilité individuelle et collectif
les services et les agents publics sont
tenus à l'exemplarité le projet de loi
relatif à la déontologie des
fonctionnaires devrait accentuer
davantage encore cette exigence dans le
même
temps deux chapitres du rapport rappelle
chacune et chacun d'entre nous citoyens
contribuables usagers des services
publics à sa responsabilité individuelle
en tant que membre de la communauté
nationale le premier
traite de la lutte contre la fraude dans
les transports urbains en île-de-fance
le taux de fraude en Île-de-France est
très supérieur au taux de fraude qu'on
peut constater dans des réseaux qui sont
comparables et le second de la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale où un certain
nombre d'améliorations législatives sont
intervenues mais où les les résultats ne
sont pas encore à la hauteur des
attentes monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs pour conclure
ce que le rapport de la Cour met en
d'évidence pourrait se se résumer en en
quelques phrases qui ne résume pas
évidemment sa sa lecture premièrement
des efforts de réforme structur sont
encore nécessaires si l'on souhaite que
la France garde la maîtrise de ses choix
souverains deuxièmement ces efforts
doivent s'appuyer sur des décisions
assumées et misise en œuvre avec rigueur
troisièmement des voies possibles de
réforme existent à la porter des
décideurs publics à condition de faire
preuve de détermination dans la conduite
du changement d'accorder davantage
d'attention au résultats et de viser une
plus grande efficience et une plus
grande clarté de l'action publique
les ministres en conviennent eux-mêmes
le plus souvent je vous invite à lire
également les réponses qu'ils nous
adressent et qui figure après chaque
chapitre du rapport il conteste peu nos
constats et nos recommandations alors il
vous appartient ainsi qu'au gouvernement
de vous inspirer si vous le souhaitez
bien
évidemment de nos contributions de
reprendre nos recommandations pour
conduire les réformes que vous
considérez comme prioritaires ou lég
je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci merci monsieur le Premier
Président Monsieur le Premier Président
le SAT vous donne acte du dépôt du
rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes et
je vais donner la parole maintenant à
madame la présidente de la commission
des finances et ce pour 10
minutes avez la parole madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Président mes chers
collègues cette séance de remise du
rapport public annuel de la Cour des
Comptes est un moment symboliquement
important qui illustre l'assistance que
la Cour des comptes apporte au Parlement
comme le prévoit la Constitution elle
est à la fois l'occasion de faire le
point sur les relations entre le Sénat
et la Cour des comptes et de nourrir de
futurs échanges le rapport public annuel
commence comme c'est désormais la
tradition par une insertion consacrée à
la situation des finances publiques
alors que le semestre européen bat son
plein nous serons la semaine prochaine à
Bruxelles avec le rapporteur général et
François Marc nos travaux des prochaines
semaines seront largement consacrés à
l'analyse du programme de stabilité et à
la programmation des finances publiques
nous devrons évaluer la politique du
gouvernement en matière de finances
publiques qui selon mon appréciation qui
bien entendu ne peut engager la totalité
des commissaire des finances se
caractérise par une maîtrise sans
précédent de l'évolution des dépenses
afin fin dans un contexte de croissance
faible de permettre des allègements
fiscaux et sociaux substantiels en
faveur des entreprises et des ménage
tout en respectant une trajectoire de
réduction du déficit public pour cela la
Cour des comptes présente des éléments
techniques qui souvent complètent les
travaux du rapporteur général et des
rapporteurs spéciaux par exemple sur
l'élasticité des prélèvements
obligatoires à la croissance sur les
aléas qui entourent le respect des
objectifs de maîtrise des dépenses ou
encore sur la traject de soldes
structurel cela nous est très utile même
si la politique budgétaire n'est que
l'une des composantes de la politique
économique et que notre réflexion
politique sur le bon dosage entre
recettes dépenses et réduction du
déficit doit intégrer d'autres éléments
comme par exemple les conséquences sur
la croissance et l'emploi mais ce n'est
pas l'objet de notre séance de ce
matin le rapport public annuel de la
Cour des comptes c'est dans l'esprit de
nos concitoyens cette mosaïque annuelle
d'insertion sur des sujets nombreux et
variés qui nous plongent dans la
diversité de notre vie économique et
administrative nous ne pouvons pas les
évoquer tous aujourd'hui en revanche il
nous appartient de nous en saisir soit
pour approfondir nos connaissances sur
un sujet soit pour donner des suites
politiques au constats ou
recommandations de la Cour des comptes
lorsque nous le jugeons utile dès le 2
mars prochain nous organiserons en
commission des finances des auditions
sur le contrôle fiscal qui fait l'objet
d'une insertion dans le rapport nous
avons constitué un groupe de travail sur
le financement des infrastructures de
transport et notre commission entendait
hier les dirigeants de la Société du
Grand Paris je ne doute pas que ses
membres tireront un grand profit des
développement du rapport sur les
transport froviaire en île-de-fance
d'autres insertions recevront sans doute
des suites sous une forme ou sous une
autre je pense à celle sur Transdev et
Veolia car rien de ce qui touche à la
Caisse des Dépôts ne nous est
indifférent à celle sur les
biocarburants qui formulent des
propositions de nature fiscale ou encore
dans le domaine qui m'est cher de
l'administration territoriale de l'État
à celle sur le contrôle de l'égalité qui
pourra nourrir les travaux de notre
rapporteur spécial Hervé Marseille à la
suite du rapport de Maurice Vincent sur
la spphile l'insertion sur Dexia vient
compléter notre information je voudrais
justement insister cette année sur la
complémentarité entre les travaux du
Sénat et ceux de la Cour des comptes
ainsi que sur la bonne coordination de
nos activités la commission des finances
a adopté la semaine dernière son
programme de contrôle budgétaire qui a
été rendu public a été transmis à la
Cour des comptes comme chaque année ce
programme de contrôle comprend des
enquêtes dont la réalisation est confiée
à la cour cette année HR gatolin Vincent
etblé vous ont demandé un travail sur
les archives national Éric Doliger sur
l'enseignement français à l'étranger et
Vincent capo hélas sur la compétitivité
du transport aérien avant la prochaine
loi de finance vous transmettrez au
rapporteur général une enquête sur les
dépenses fiscales en faveur du
développement durable et dans un mois
marc Laménie rendra publque le rapport
qu'il élabore sur la base d'une enquête
sur la journée défense et citoyenneté
que vous lui avez remise en tant que
président de la commission des finances
je voudrais dire ma satisfaction de
constater que les rapporteurs de la
commission des finances utilisent les
enquêtes que nous vous demandons pour
nourir leurs propositions politiques
sans pour autant épouser
systématiquement les recommandations de
la Cour et sans bien entendu vous le
comprendrez que j'y soit titre personnel
toujours favorable je pense aux
initiatives qu'a prise notre rapporteur
général alberrique de Montgolfier lors
de l'examen du projet de loi de finances
pour 2016 lorsqu'il a présenté des
amendements visant à réduire la masse
salariale de l'État je pense à philippe
Dallier qui a utiliser l'enquête sur les
aides personnelles au logement pour
préparer des amendements tendant à
étudier les modalités de création d'une
base de données dans le but de connaître
la surface des logements des
allocataires et à lutter contre la
fraude ou encore à étudier les
conditions dans lesquelles les revenus
des parents pourraient être pris en
compte dans l'attribution des aPL je
pense aux propositions de Francis de
lâre sur l'aide à la complémentaire
santé pour les personnes âgées ou encore
au rapport d'Alain oupert et Yannick
bautrell sur la filière forêt bois qui a
suscité beaucoup de débats et de
réflexion depuis sa publication au mois
d'avril
la semaine dernière le directeur général
de l'Agence des participations de l'État
évoqué devant la commission des finances
les conséquence de la mise en œuvre des
recommandations de l'enquête demandée
par philippe Dallier et alberérique de
Montgolfier sur le recours par l'État
aux consultants extérieurs n nous nous
ne nous bornons pas à utiliser les
enquêtes que nous vous demandons mais
essayons de tirer profit de l'ensemble
de la production de la Cour des comptes
dans nos travaux de contrôle ainsi que
dans le cadre des discussions
législatives ainsi le rapporteur général
lors de l'examen du dernier projet de
loi de finance
rectificative se fondant sur des
rapports de la Cour des comptes pour
approuver les modifications proposées
dans les règles de fonctionnement du
FCTVA ou encore la réforme du compte de
commerce régie industrielle des
établissements
pénitentiaires j'en profite pour
signaler que le calendrier des travaux
de la Cour des comptes ne permet pas
toujours de les exploiter au mieux c'est
ainsi que nous avons reçu le rapport du
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
sur la TVA après le vote du projet de
loi de finan et du collectif budgétaire
nous avons reçu cette semaine un référé
consacré au dispositif ISF PME qui
aurait sans doute été utile à notre
rapporteur général lorsqu'il a présenté
en collectif budgétaire un amendement
qui n'a pas été retenu mais qui va dans
le même sens que ce que préconise la
cour aurait-il eu plus de succès si
l'analyse de la Cour avait été
disponible au mois de décembre je ne
sais pas l'évolution toujours plus posit
des relations entre la Cour des comptes
et le Parlement doit beaucoup à l'état
d'esprit qui a été insufflé il y aura 15
ans au mois d'août par l'adoption de la
loi organique relative aux lois de
finances les enquêtes demandées en
application de son article 582 ont
conduit les magistrats à travailler avec
les rapporteurs spéciaux à l'origine de
la saisine les auditions publiques
organisées suite à la remise de ces
enquêtes ont transformé les présidents
de chambre en habitués de nos salles de
réunions et je profiter monsieur le
Premier Président pour saluer l'ensemble
de ceux qui à vos côtés travaillent dans
cet état d'esprit le rapport public
annuel n'est plus l'unique grand
rendez-vous entre la cour et le
Parlement chaque année le premier
président vient désormais nous présenter
le rapport sur l'exécution budgétaire de
l'année précédente celui sur la
certification des comptes de l'État et
celui sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances
publiques pour toutes ces raisons je me
réjouis de initiative conjointe du
président du Sénat et du premier
président de la Cour des comptes visant
à marquer le coup et organiser au Sénat
pour les 15 ans de la LOLF une journée
d'étude consacrée aux apports de la
comptabilité générale en matière de
contrôle parlementaire et de
transparence des comptes publics mes
chers collègues je sais que vous êtes
impatient de vous plonger dans la
lecture des
1335 pages que le premier président
vientp on va maîiser tout ça madame la
Présidente sur le bureau du Sénat et
c'est pourquoi après avoir à nouveau
remercié le premier président de sa
grande disponibilité je pense notre
président va donner la parole à mon
collègue Alain Milon je vous remercie de
votre
attention merci Madame la
présidentez saluer les deux rapporteurs
généraux alberrique de montgulfier et
Jean-Marie
vanlerenberg qui partagent cette écoute
qui vont se plonger
immédiatement dans l'ensemble des
documents la parole est à Alain Milon
président de la Commission ion des
affaires
sociales monsieur le Président vous avez
la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président de la Cour des comptes
madame la présidente de la commission
des finances mes chers
collègues la présentation du rapport
public annuel marque l'un des temps
forts de l'assistance au Parlement dans
le contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
mission confiée à la Cour des comptes
par l'article 47-2 de notre Constitution
rythmé par les différentes publications
de la cour cette mission s'effectue tout
au long de l'année et revê une
importance majeur dans le contexte que
nous connaissons la ressource publique
est devenue rare et les déficits sont
élevés plus que jamais il est nécessaire
de tracer les voies d'une action
publique plus
économe la contribution de la cour des
compte est de ce point de vue essentiel
en particulier pour la sphère sociale
qui représente je vous le rappelle près
de la moitié de nos finances publiques
c'est pourquoi la commission des
affaires sociales porte toujours
monsieur le Président un très grand
intérêt aux analyses et propositions de
la cour qu'elle figure dans le rapport
public annuel le rapport annuel sur les
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale les rapports de certification
les rapports thématiques ou les enquêtes
qui sont effectué à notre demande le
rapport que vient de nous présenter le
premier président fait le point au
sortir de la période budgétaire sur la
situation des finances publiques alors
que nous constatons sur ce sujet une
tendance du gouvernement à se satisfaire
de résultats limités la cour apporte
quelques temp quelques tempéraments
bienvenue le déficit ne s'est que
faiblement réduit en 2015 alors que
persistaient les effets de traain du
choc fiscal des années précédentes la
Cour constate que les baisses de
prélèvement décidé pour 2015 représentai
14 milliards d'euros mais qu'elles sont
en partie été neutralisé par 10
milliards de prélévement supplémentaires
résultant de mesures décidées
antérieurement le premier bilan du pacte
de
responsabilité en terme d'allègement de
charg fiscal et sociale apparaît donc
encore bien mince au moment où certains
voudraient exiger des entreprises
davantage de contrepartie en terme
d'emploi car au-delà des comptes pu
c'est bien la situation d'emploi qui
nous préoccupe tous et c'est autour de
cette problématique d'actualité que je
centreraai mon intervention sur ce
terrain notre pays est en situation
d'échec majeur 90000 chômeurs de plus en
475000 depuis
2011 notre dynamisme démographique dont
il faut par ailleurs se réjouir bien que
fragilisé lui aussi n'est pas seul en
cause loin de là la France se distingue
surtout par une faiblesse préoccupante
de la création d'emplois 57000 emplois
créés en 2 ans dans le secteur privé
autre sujet d'inquiétude alors que le
chômage est massif l'évolution des
coûtes salariaux semble déconnecté de
cette situation consacrant ainsi un
dualisme désormais bien ancré du marché
du travail nos voisins qui ont fait des
choix différents ont vu leur situation
s'améliorer sur la même période l'
l'Italie a créé près de 300000 emplois
l'Allemagne plus de 480000 et l'Espagne
650000 comment ne pas faire le lien
entre l'état des finances publiques le
choix d'une augmentation massive des
prélèvements pour y répondre et la
situation de l'emploi nous pouvons
trouver matière à réflexion dans
certaines analyses de ce rapport annuel
et dans d'autres travaux récent de la
Cour la multiplication des contrats
aidés et la création d'emploi public ne
sont que de piètres palliatifs qui ont
de surcroix pour effet d'alourdir encore
les charges publiques le montage de
dispositifs complexes n'a pas davantage
stimuler la création d'emploi je
constate que la Cour partage sur le
contrat de génération le même
diagnostique que la commission des
affaires sociales qui en déplore l'échec
depuis 2 ans et souvenez-vous à ce sujet
de cette phrase devenue célèbre quand
c'est flou c'est qu'il y a un loup en
2013 le gouvernement s'était fixé comme
objectif 500000 binôes sur le quinquena
nous n'en sommes qu'à un peu plus de
50000 les préconisation de la cour qui
appellent à une refondte du dispositif
rejoignent donc pleinement les
préoccupations de la commission des
Affaires sociale l'efficacité de
l'action publique ce n'est pas seulement
celle des dispositifs
c'est aussi celle des organisations nous
avons ainsi pris note du constat dressé
par la Cour sur le fond de solidarité
elle propose de transférer ses missions
à une structure mieux à même de
recouvrer de façon effective les
montants dus par les fonctionnaires au
titre du financement des allocations
pour les chômeurs non indemnisés
monsieur le Président la cososse nous
aussi nous semble pouvoir remplir cette
mission évoquant l'exercice budgétaire
2016 la cour des te indique qu'un des
risques principaux d'écart à la
prévision résulte et je cite de la
surestimation des économies attendu de
la nouvelle convention d'assurance
chômage le gouvernement a en effet
intégré dans ses prévisions 800 millions
d'euros au titre de la réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage notre
rapporteur général Jean-Marie vanenberg
avait émis de fortes réserves sur les
économies attendues des régimes à
gestion paritaire une édiic et retraite
complémentair estimé à 4 milliards sur
la période 2015-27 en l'absence de toute
disposition concrète permettant d'y
parvenir force de reconnaître que les
négociations sur la retraite
complémentairire ont abouti à un accord
qui porte une véritable réforme
ambitieuse et structurante les économies
attendues à court terme dépendent d'un
niveau d'inflation qui risque de ne pas
être atteint mais les fondements de la
réforme à moyen terme ont été posés je
rappelle que la Cour des comptes avait
d'ailleurs établi un rapport
particulièrement éclairant sur ce point
l'an passé les partenaires sociaux
pourront-il même en y étant fortement
incité par le gouvernement aboutir à une
réforme comparable de l'assurance
chômage sur lequel sujet sur lequel la
Cour a s'est également prononcé très
récemment les négociations sur la
nouvelle convention d'assurance chômage
qui s'ouvriront le 22 février prochain
seront à cet égard décisives avec un
déficit de 4 ,4 milliards d'euros et une
dette de près de 26 milliards d'euros en
2015 la situation financière de
l'assurance chômage n'est plus tenable
une réforme est d'autant plus nécessaire
que le déficit comporte une part
structurelle non négligeable mise en
lumière par les travaux de l'Unedic la
commission des affaires sociales partage
entièrement le constat du gouvernement
selon lequel je cite à nouveau en
l'absence d'efforts raisonnable à court
terme la pérennité du régime pourrait
être remise en cause les pistes tracées
par le rapport du gouvernement sur la
situation financière de l'assurance
Dommage sont claires réduction de la
durée d'indemnisation dégressivité des
allocations baisse du ratio
d'indemnisation par jour cotisé baisse
du plancher d'indemnisation et hausse
des cotisations aucune de ces mesures
prise isolément n'apportera à l'évidence
de réponses durabl à la situation
financière de l'assurance chômage comme
pour les retraites complémentaires c'est
un panier de mesures qui devra être mise
en place cependant en alourdissant le
coût du travail la hausse des
cotisations serait contradictoire avec
le renforcement des allaigements décidés
il y a 2 ans la Commission des
affffaires sociales n est donc pas
favorable cette réforme devra surtout
être mise au service du retour à
l'emploi avec une indemnisation à la
fois protectrice et incitative
pour conclure je voudrais de nouveau à
l'occasion du dépôt de ce rapport annuel
souligner l'apport des travaux de la
Cours des comptes à la nécessaire
analyse des liens étroits entre les
finances publiques la protection sociale
et la situation d' l'emploi au sein du
Parlement chacun y réagira en fonction
de sa sensibilité et pourra en tirer ses
propres conclusions il s'agit en tout
cas d'une contribution à la réflexion et
au débat au nom de la commission des
affffaires sociales je voulais une
nouvelle fois saluer je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général nous en
avons terminé avec la présentation de de
ce rapport je voudrais vous remercier
pour ce rapport et vous remercier à
nouveau pour les troites relations qui
existent notamment pour éclairer les
commissions et les
délégations je vais demander maintenant
conformément à la formule aux huissiers
de bien vouloir vous
réaccompagner monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général en vous
remerciant à
nouveau voilà pour la remise du rapport
annuel de la Cour des comptes vous avez
pu entendre l'allocution du premier
président de la Cour des comptes Didier
Migot suivi des interventions d'abord de
la présidente de la commission des
finances la socialiste Michel André
suivi du discours du président LR de la
commission des affaires sociales alain
Milon toute autre chose à présent
puisque je vous propose de passer aux
travaux de la mission d'information sur
la place de l'islam en France qui a
auditionné mercredi dernier Alain grche
alain grche est journaliste au Monde
diplomatique il est spécialiste du
Moyen-Orient lors de cette audition il
est revenu sur les rapports
qu'entretiennent la société française et
de l'islam notamment la méconnaissance
par la majorité de la Société française
des différents courants de l'islam en
France également pour ce journaliste et
bien la laïcité et l'islam sont
parfaitement compatibles il a rappelé
que la plupart l'immense majorité des
musulmans appliquent en France les lois
de la République tout de suite donc
retour à cette audition c'était mercredi
au Sénat
nous recevons cet après-midi Monsieur
Alain grche qui est l'ancien rédacteur
en chef puis directeur adjoint du Monde
diplomatique jusqu'à la fin de l'année
passée l'année
2015 monsieur grche vous animer
aujourd'hui le blog nouvelle d'Orient et
vous avez publié plusieurs livres sur
l'islam comme l'islam la République et
le monde en 2004 ou encore l'islam en
question c'est un livre d'entretien avec
tariic Ramadan qui est paru en
2000 monsieur le bureau de notre mission
d'information d'information pardon a
souhaité vous entendre parce qu'ayant
couvert le proche orient durant de
nombreuses années vous êtes un excellent
connaisseur de cette région compliquée
et des tensions religieuses qui la
traverse certes ce sont des pays où la
population est ta majorité musulmane ce
qui n'est pas le cas chez nous mais la
manière dont il gère la coexistence
entre les différentes communautés
confessionnel pourrai fournir des points
de comparaison intéressants avec la
situation française si vous en êtes
d'accord je vous propose dans un premier
temps de non seulement avoir autour de
de 15 minutes à propos limininaire pour
nous faire part de votre réflexion
générale nous pensions nous
souhaiterions en particulier recueillir
votre point de vue sur les difficultés
que l'exercice du culte musulman a pu ou
peut encore rencontrer en France sur les
conditions que l'islam
euh et sur les conditions pour que
l'islam puisse s'y épanouir en bonne
harmonie avec les autres institutions et
bien bien sûr mes collègues ici présents
euh pourront vous poser un certain
nombre de questions en général les
auditions se déroule autour d'une heure
un peu plus on n'est pas à quelques
minutes près donc voilà je vous remercie
encore de de vous être rendu disponible
je vais vous laisser la parole en vous
précisant que euh cette séance comme la
suivante est enregistrée et fait l'objet
donc d'une captation d'une captation euh
vidéo donc on retrouve et on retrouvera
sur le site du Sénat l'ensemble de nos
échanges merci
oui appuyz encore
voilà voilà là c'est bon bien merci tout
d'abord merci pour votre
invitation je voudrais dire en
introduction que je pense que la mission
de votre commission est extrêmement
importante parce que l'avenir avec
l'avenir des communautés musulmanes en
France il n'en va pas seulement de la
cohésion nationale de notre société mais
il va il en va aussi de nos relations
avec le monde musulman et aujourd'hui on
voit bien à quel point les deux sont
liés c'est-à-dire que le monde ce qui se
passe dans le monde musulman qui est
notre voisin géographique et ce qui se
passe chez nous il y a une interaction
et
donc je pense notre capacité à régler
ou à améliorer les relations avec les
communautés musulmanes en France est
tout à fait
décisive pour aussi pour la place de la
France dans le monde je voudrais dire
d'abord que quand on parle des
communautés musulmanes en France c'est
une généralisation si je puis dire il y
a 30 ans personne ne parlait des
musulmans de France on disait les
maghrébains on disait les Africains
c'est une formulation qui est née dans
les années 80 et qui est en partie
trompeuse en partie trompeuse parce
qu'elle crée l'idée d'une communauté
musulmane unie euh qui serait regroupé
qui qui auraiit des objectifs plus ou
moins similaires et des situations
similaires or ce n'est pas du tout le
cas je crois euh d'abord parce que les
communautés musulmanes sont divisées en
fonction
de de des nationalités d'origine et vous
savez à quel point le fait de venir
d'Algérie du baroc ou de Tunisie pour se
limiter à ces exemples est important
pour pour les les gens qui viennent de
ces pays ou même qui en sont simplement
originaires dans les parents ou les
grands-parents viennent de de de ces
pays et ensuite parce qu'il y a
différentes pratiques de l'islam aussi
dans ces pays c'est-à-dire que
l'islam je dirais pakistanais ou l'islam
algérien ou l'islam africain n'est pas
tout à fait tout à fait le même mais
l'autre élément aussi qui est important
c'est que vous savez qu'en France il n'y
a pas de de statistique ni ethnique ni
religieuse c'est qu'on a pas le droit de
demander aux gens s'ils sont ou en tous
les cas de les définir euh par la
religion c'est vous savez c'est un sujet
qui fait débat bon je c'est comme c'est
comme ça aux États-Unis ils ont une
pratique qui est intéressante puisque
les statistiques ethniques sont faites à
partir d'autodéclaration c'est-à-dire
que les gens disent eux-mêmes ce qu'ils
veulent être et que depuis une dizaine
d'années vous pouvez choisir plusieurs
origines donc vous pouvez très bien
inscrire dans un déclaration donc
dans démographique de dire je suis blanc
et noir c'est tout à fait légal bon en
France c'est pas ça mais du coup quand
on parle des chiffres de musulmans en
France on ne sait pas de combien on
parle vous avez les vous avez pu voir 4
millions 5 millions 6 millions on sait
pas très bien la seule chose que l'on
sait c'est les gens qui quand il y a des
on interroge les musulmans on interroge
les gens qui se définissent comme
musulmans mais on se rend compte que en
fait sur ces 5 ou 6 millions de
musulmans à peu près la moitié
définissent comme musulmans les autres
on ne sait pas alors on a peut-être
c'est une réflexion à voir un phénomène
qui est un peu celui aujourd'hui des qui
a été historiquement celui des des
communautés juives vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens se
définissent comme juif sans sans être
croyant et aujourd'hui vous avez un un
phénomène un peu qui est en train de de
à mon avis de progresser c'est-à-dire
une une le sentiment d'appartenir à une
communauté d'autant plus qu'il y a le
sentiment d'être une communauté
communauté minoritaire et d'être une
communauté stigmatisée et donc il y a ça
qui est qui est important l'autre chose
aussi qui est très importante quand on
parle des musulmans c'est la présence
des jeunes
et je dirais il constiue la majorité de
ces musulmans il sont nés en France ils
ont été élevés dans les écoles de la
République ils vivent pour certains dans
les quartiers difficiles et ils sont
plus nombreux dans les quartiers
difficil mais ne vivent pas que dans ces
quartiers difficiles et je dois dire que
c'est ceux dont qu'on entend le moins et
auquel on est le moins à l'écoute quels
que soient les nos interlocuteurs
musulmans c'est souvent des gens de
génération ce que les ce que les jeunes
appellent de manière un peu enfin de
manière dénigrante les blédar
c'est-à-dire des gens qui sont qui sont
souvent nés à l'étranger qui ne sont pas
français qui parfois parlent mal
français mais qui sont considérés comme
les représentants des de la Communauté
française et il y a donc une tendance
chez nous à traiter les les musulmans en
général comme mineurs mais les jeunes
encore plus comme mineurs vous savez
qu'en France malheureusement l'essentiel
de de la de la situation enfin de des
communautés algériennne marocaines turqu
et cetera
euh nous réglons les problèmes avec eux
avec les ambassades de ces républiques
et pas seulement avec les ambassades
avec les services de renseignement de
ces républiques c'est quand nous avons
un problème dans les communautés
marocaines on va voir l'ambassade du
Maroc et on leur demande de régler le
problème et au moment même où on dit
nous voulons un islam de France et il y
a là vraiment quelque chose de qui est
contradictoire et qui devrait amener à
une espèce de révolution dont le premier
élément serait sans doute que d'arrêter
de de faire que le ministère de
l'intérieur soit chargé des cultes en
France on ne voit pas pourquoi c'est le
ministère de l'Intérieur en France qui
qui qui s'occupe des cultes et pas le
ministère de la justice c'est pas une
affaire d'ordre public les religions
c'est une une affaire on en fait
malheureusement une affaire de police et
je pense que ça a des des des
conséquences
négatives quand on parle de la
représentation des musulmans en France
le
oui oui mais ça un côté symbolique ici
qui qui me semble dépasser ça parce que
effectivement ce n'est pas l'aménagement
du territoire on va pas le négocier
avec on on va pas le négocier
avec l'ambassade d'Algérie ou
l'ambassade de Turquie en France c'est
quand même à mon avis une différence
quand on parle de la représentation
évidemment on a le Conseil français du
culte musulman mais ça mérite quelques
précisions parce qu'il y a une très
grande confusion sur ce conseil c'est un
organe du culte or il y a une chez nous
une tendance à faire que ce soit le
porte-parole de la communauté musulmane
comme vous savez pour les Juifs il y a
deux organes tout à fait différents qui
qui sont le conshistoire Juif qui est
l'interlocuteur normal de l'État comme
l'Église catholique est l'interlocuteur
normal de l'État pour les affaires du
culte pour nommer les homoniers par
exemple dans les prisons dans les
hôpitaux et cetera et puis il y a le
CRIF qui est une représentation
autoproclamé d'une partie de la
communauté juive mais le
CFCM je répète a vocation d'être
l'organe du culte c'est et effectivement
parmi les petites avancées que a permis
le CSC il y a notamment la question des
homoniers de des homoniers dans l'armée
des homoniers dans les mosquées et
cetera mais je pense qu'il y a une
tendance à faire du de ce CFCM le
représentant des musulmans en France et
le le CFCM à part l'if sur lequel je
vais revenir est composé de fédérations
qui sont en fait les représentants de de
l'Algérie essentiellement Algérie Maroc
et Turquie là aussi c'est un problème
quand nous
demandons la la création
d'un d'un islam de de France je voudrais
dire un mot sur le l'UOIF donc c'est
l'Union des organisations islamiques de
France et tout le monde sait proche des
Frères musulmans qui est une
organisation conservatrice mais en même
temps une organisation très légaliste
c'est-à-dire c'est une organisation qui
est qui applique la loi et qui qui n'est
pas une organisation réellement de
contestation c'est aussi une
organisation qui a en profonde crise
depuis une dizaine d'années notamment
avec les jeunes générations parce que
ils sont coupés des jeunes générations
parce que ils sont dirigés par des gens
d'une autre d'une autre génération et
qu'ils ont beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
s'implanter chez ces nouveaux musulmans
qui sont nés alors eux vraiment en
France qui sont qui sont de culture
française et qu'on voit de de plus en
plus partout
c'est-à-dire dans les universités ça
peut se voir on peut trouver que c'est
négatif mais par le nombre de filles qui
portent le foulard à l'université c'est
aussi un signe d'ascension aujourd'hui
d'ascension sociale et ces jeunes ne se
reconnaissent pas ni dans l'uif ni dans
les autres organisation euh du du
CFCM euh
le l'autre courant aujourd'hui qui
existe dans le dans l'islam c'est le ce
qu'on appelle le salafisme la différence
entre le salafisme et les Frères
musulmans au-delà des problèmes de
doctrine dans lequel je ne rentrerai pas
c'est que l'ueif c'est une vraie
organisation centralisée avec des
sections avec une discipline assez assez
rigoureuse donc on peut dire qui est é
Luu auf et qui ne l''est pas mais on
peut pas dire qui est salafiste et non
et il y a 20 courants différents du
salafisme qui vont des salafistes
quiétiste c'est-à-dire ceux qui prônent
l'appolitisme au salafist djihadistes
ceux qui prônent le djihad il faut
savoir que historiquement le salafisme
qui a été exporté très largement par
l'Arabie Saoudite était un salafisme qui
est
c'est-à-dire c'est un sal film très euh
conservateur réactionnaire on pourrait
dire sur le plan des meœurs sur le plan
sur toute une série de plans mais
c'était pas c'était pas jusque dans les
années 2000 un un courant conserv un
courant contestataire aujourd'hui il est
devenu contestataire y compris à
l'intérieur de l'Arabie saoudite où il y
a des contestations qui se font au nom
du du salafisme mais c'est un courant
aujourd'hui qui qui
progresse dont le discours essentiel
même chez les gens qui ne sont pas je
dirais des radicaux ou qui ne sont pas
des gens qui prônent la violence c'est
de dire nous sommes dans une société
impie et nous n'avons rien à faire avec
cette société nous voulons vivre à côté
de ces sociétés avec l'idée à terme
d'émigrer en terre
d'islam et je crois que c'est un c'est
un courant qui depuis une dizaine
d'années a progressé de manière
relativement
importante parce que il répond à une un
sentiment de beaucoup de notamment de
jeunes d'être stigmatisé aujourd'hui par
la société par les médias et d'avoir
l'impression d'être totalement sous sous
pression et je crois que c'est c'est
quelque chose auquel il faut vraiment
accorder de l'importance je dirais pas
plus que le que les risques évidemment
de de de passage à des actes violents
mais c'est quand même quelque chose
d'inquiétant de voir des gens qui se
disent nous ne sommes plus nous ne
sommes plus français euh je veux dire ça
s'appuie sur quelque chose enfin sur un
double phénomène qu'il faut avoir un qui
est objectif c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui
quand vous vous appelez Mohammed ou
Fatima vous avez quatre ou CIN fois de
moins de chance à diplôme égal de
trouver un travail il y a eu une
étude très très bonne faête à propos de
du Sénégal où on a pris le même panel si
on peut dire de vous savez qu'au Sénégal
il y a 10 % de chrétiens donc on a fait
des CV
avec le même CV avec prénom chrétien
prénom musulman avant même de si vous
voulez le il y a qure ou C fois plus de
chance d'avoir une réponse si on a un
prénom chrétien qu'on un prénom musulman
voilà donc ça c'est quelque chose que
les jeunes vivent dans dans la réalité y
compris une partie des jeunes qui ont
réussi socialement et puis l'autre
l'autre aspect qui me semble
aussi l'autre aspect qui me semble aussi
important c'est la des médias
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui l'islam est
sans arrêt euh je veux dire devant de la
scène avec l'impression de ces de
ces jeunes musulmans de d'être
effectivement désigné désignés du doigt
alors je répète ces jeunes musulmans il
y a une partie qui est les populations
défavorisées dans des et dont on parle
souvent mais c'est aussi des gens qui
sont d'une certaine manière le symbole
de la réussite du du modèle français
c'est-à-dire des gens qui ont réussi
leurs études qui soit ilsu de couches
populaires soit de couches non
populaires il y a maintenant une une
vraie bourgeoisie disons musulmane et
qui n'ont pas ce qui n'ont pas le
sentiment d'être intégré et qui ont en
plus ce sentiment de n'avoir personne
qui parl en leur nom et quand il voi à
la télévision les gens que qui sont
invités je dirais ça provoque encore
plus de haine je vais donner un exemple
qui est c'est l'exemple de l'imam
chalgoumi je veux dire qui est un une
espèce d'idole comme ça des médias je
peux vous dire qu' n'a aucun poids dans
la communauté musulmane et non seulement
ça les les musulmans prennent sa ses
prestations comme une insulte euh je je
pour enfin je veux dire ce n'est pas
simplement il y a eu quelques temps
Laurent Geoffrin qui a fait un
éditorialiste pour dire les gens qui
attaquent chalgoumi c'est des gens qui
sont contre la République et cetera il a
une grande influence dans l'Islam la J
journaliste du Figaro qui est vraiment
pas susceptible d'être accusé
de je vais dire de philo Islam a dit je
n'ai pas rencontré dans mon travail de
journaliste un musulman qui trouve que
shalgoui parle en sonement mais c'est
lui qui apparaît à la télévision ou bien
ce sont des intellectuels qui disent
exactement ce que nous nous avons à dire
c'est tant mieux je c'est des
intellectuels musulmans dans le sens où
ils ont des non musulmans mais où les
musulmans croyants n'ont pas qu'il
parlent en leur nom donc il y a là vrai
un vrai problème de euh représentation
et là-dessus je vais terminer pour
rajouter quelque chose qui qui risque de
vous fâcher encore plus que tout ce que
j'ai dit c'est je vais vous parler de
tare Ramadan je vais vous en pas parler
parce que c'est quelqu'un que je
fréquente depuis 20 ans avec qui j'ai
fait des débats j'ai fait un livre j'ai
fait des débats en français en arabe
parce que je parle l'arabe et donc je
peux vous dire que l'idée qu'il tient un
tout ble discours est absolument euh
fausse je l'ai entendu dans les publics
ailleurs qu'en Franceà dire musulman
tenir des propos beaucoup plus dur et
beaucoup plus autocritique de l'islam
que ce qu' fait ce qu'il fait en France
est-ce qu'il a varié au cours des 20 ans
que je j'ai franquenté oui il a varié il
a eu de des positions qui ont qui ont
été différentes il a évolué comme
beaucoup de gens et quand on me dit le
double discours j'ai dit écoutez oui
c'est vrai nous devons dénoncer les
doubles discours en France nous avons
élu un président de la République sur un
discours de gauche évidemment il fait
une politique de gauche le fait que des
responsables politiques tiennent des
discours qui soi pas toujours les mêmes
je veux dire ça devrait pas être quand
même considéré comme quelque chose
d'extraordinaire mais il n'a pas de
double langage au sens il n'a pas un
programme caché ce que Tarek Ramadan dit
depuis 20 ans c'est au musulmans c'est
vous êtes parti de cette société vous
n'avez pas à avoir de complexe vous
n'avez pas à vous considérer comme
victimiser vous n'avez pas sans arrêt
dire que vous êtes victimisé à vous de
vous battre pour vos droits de citoyen
et euh je sais que on on peut débattre
de de lui et beaucoup parce qu'il est
resté plein de choses dont la plus
extraordinaire évidemment qui lui a
coûté le plus c'est la faaire du
moratoire sur la lapidation et
euh je dirais c'est c'est intéressant
parce que c'est euh ça me permet de
faire un petit comment dire
un petit dégagement sur la question de
l'islam dans le monde il y a
effectivement aujourd'hui globalement
depuis une cinquantaine d'années
largement financé par nos amis souiens
une lecture de l'islam qui est une
lecture extrêmement conservatrice et
qu'ils ont exporté dans le monde entier
à travers grâce au pétrodollar et à
travers l'exportation de milliers et de
milliers d'imams non seulement en France
mais dans T dans tous les pays et c'est
vrai qu'il y a des débats dans la
communauté musulmane quand nous parlons
de la lapidation il faut savoir deux
choses un c'est que en dehors de
l'Afghanistan quand c'était les talibans
et je crois de l'Iran il n'y a aucun
pays musulman qui a qui applique la
lapidation mais que vous n'obtiendrez
jamais d'un d'un de nos amis les chers
marocains algériens ou égyptiens
quelqu'un dire la lapidation c'est euh
contraire à l'islam malheureusement je
veux dire il faut le je je dis pas ça il
faut le regretter ce que Ramadan dit lui
en tant que musulman il dit ce que un
Américain qui serait contre la peine de
mort dirait aux États-Unis dans un pays
où la majorité de l'opinion est pour la
peine de mort demander un moratoire
n'est pas quelque chose de négatif c'est
un pas en avant positif
mais je vais terminer maintenant sur cet
aspect de de de de l'islam international
il y a effectivement un problème mais il
faut comprendre que nous ne sommes pas
face à une leure c'est on a souvent
l'impression quand on discute de l'islam
que il y a un islam don notamment la
charia qui est un un corps de doctrine
extrêmement fixe et
réactionnaire je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça le je
vais vous donner un exemple que je donne
souvent en 1952 les femmes égyptiennes
sont descendues dans la rue pour
demander le droit de vote le che del
Azhar qui est la plus grande institution
de l'islam a fait une fatoi pour dire
c'est contraire à l'islam aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus un pays musulman y compris
l'Arabie Saoudite c'est le dernier où
les femmes ne votent pas donc le
problème n'est pas de penser qu'il y a
quelque chose dans l'islam qui serait
particulièrement qui n permettrait pas
d'évoluer l'islam comme toutes les
religion comme le catholicisme comme le
judaïsme s'est adopté petit à petit aux
sociétés en fonction de lutte interne en
fonction de de de l'évolution mais il ne
faut pas avoir si vous voulez
l'impression que nous avons à faaire
aujourd'hui à
un islam figé il y a des débats à
l'intérieur de l'islam mais souvent ces
débats nous ne les voyons pas parce que
nous nous interrogons pas c'estàdire ça
nous sembl des débats très très loin de
nos de notre manière de discuter
politique mais il y a des des débats à
l'intérieur de l'Islam sur les question
de la peine de mort sur la question de
la place des femmes et cetera qui sont
importants et dont les musulmans
tiennent compte ils tiennent enfin ils
en tiennent compte en France parce que
aussi et c'est ce qui fait la
spécificité de de l'islam de France par
des musulmans aujourd'hui par rapport à
d'autres immigrations c'est qu'elle a
une dimension internationale aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas nier qu'il y a
une une fierté disons d'être musulman il
y a 1 milliard 500 millions ou 200
millions de musulmans il y a
l'impression d'appartenir à à une
communauté et ça fait que encore une
fois la question de l'islam en France ne
peut pas être ne peut pas se résoudre
simplement à l'intérieur du cadre
français mais qu'elle a une dimension
internationale merci
bien merci pour ces premierers propos je
dirais de de de présentation vous
suggère je vous propose maintenant de de
vous donner la parole un peu comme on
l'a fait les fois précédente je prends
par trois questions vous y répondez et
puis on essaie d'être aussi précis ou
direct sur vos questions pour permettre
le temps d'échange alors qui souhaite
prendre la parole monsieur carucci
monsieur oui
c'est à la fois question et en même
temps
euh au travers des propos tenus
inquiétude premier élément sincèrement
euh si on nous dit que CFCM
UOIF tout le monde en réalité a perdu le
contact avec les générations de jeunes
musulmans comme par définition ceuxl ne
sont pas organisé en en structure qui
peuvent être invité sur une radio ou une
télé ça veut veut dire que dans la
pratique on a plus du tout de
correspondants ou de gens avec qui qui
deviennent des
interlocuteurs deuxème élément
d'inquiétude c'est que vous dites bien
d'un are tranquille enfin qui qui ne
peut pas nous laisser tranquille il y a
un côté international il y a une fierté
c'est tout à fait logique d'appartenir à
une communauté musulmane mais en même
temps il y a l'espèce de rejet
d'un système qui dit bah la France est
chez vous c'est pas chez vous le système
de la République c'est le vôtre c'est
pas le vôtre et on a un peu le sentiment
de plus en plus que dans les jeunes
générations la pratique de l'Islam et le
Coran passe avant la loi de la
République et ça c'est un vrai sujet
parce que si d'un côté on essaie
d'organiser l'islam de France pour faire
en sorte que bah comme les autres
religions ils soi intégrés il participe
à la vie publique et cetera mais qu'on
nous dit un bah non vous n'y arriverez
pas parce que toute façon c'est pas du
tout leur position c'est même pas leur
souhait ça va quand même poser une vraie
difficulté ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire à qui on parle tout à l'heure nous
recevons le président du
CFCM on va lui dire bonjour pu on lu
direa au
fait qui vous qui vous reconnaît qui qui
vous êtes qui dans le fond vous avez été
élu par vos pères enfin vos pères sont
présélectionnés par vous-même donc en
réalité à qui on parle et le le vrai
sujet c'est que nous ici nous ne sommes
pas là pour nous imisser dans les débats
théologiques au sein de la communauté
musulmane pas plus que la communauté
juive ou la communauté chrétienne mais
en revanche notre rôle ici c'est de
savoir comment euh ça peut fonctionner
dans le cadre de la République et
l'inquiétude c'est de dire est-ce que ça
peut fonctionner dans le cas de la
République parce que si c'est non et si
la fierté internationale fait que en
réalité c'est le corant qui prime sur
les lois de la République on a un sujet
on pourra pas appliquer de la même
manière par rapport aux autres
communautés alors là-dessus comment vous
voyez en réalité non pas la
représentation et tout bon ça j'ai
compris mais l'intégration et la
possibilité de dire oui les musulmans de
France sont intégrés entre guillemets
dans la République je suis pas dans la
société ni rien c'est très compliqué
mais ils acceptent les lois de la
République Monsieur boncarer puis
monsieur grer
oui merci merci Madame Présidente je je
ne souhaite pas intervenir sur la
diversité des mondes musulmans ou sur
les questions personnel je voudrais
simplement
avoiris de notre intervenant
sur la comment dire la solution qui a
son sens peut-être trouvée en système
français basé sur la séparation de
l'Église et de l'État et euh un islam
qui repose très largement sur une vision
dans laquelle il n'y a pas de
dissociation
entre l'organisation institutionnelle du
du pays et la vision religieuse euh
comment à votre sens monsieur il est
possible euh
d'arriver à ce que pour l'islam de
France il y ait une dissociation
entre la les convictions religieuses la
manière de vivre sa religion et
l'organisation
institutionnelle du pays comment peut-on
envisager l'application de l'esprit de
1905 je ne vais pas du tout sur le
terrain de la laïcité je suis simplement
sur la séparation entre entre les les
deux comment appliquer cette séparation
à votre sens à l'islam en France ou à
l'islam de France suivant la formule que
chacun pourra
préférer alors Monsieur grodidier puis
vous répondrez à cette première
série merci le d'abord le euh vis
revenir sur effectivement votre
appréciation qui qui peut poser problèm
il faut qu'on nous on pose le problème
avant d'envisager de répondre
effectivement la description euh assez
précise de d'un islam en France organisé
euh à partir des communautés d'origine
nationale en relation avec ses pays
d'origine à la fois la République est
dans une difficulté en disant que c'est
un moindre mal parce que ça garantit un
islam malquite ou un islam turc des
rêves que que les influences habites qui
s'exercent par ailleurs mais qui en même
temps est totalement paradoxal quand on
veut un un un islam de France et non pas
en France voilà donc le le CFCM est
l'heureuse tentative en tout cas la
tentative bienvenue pour essayer d'y
remédier mais avec effectivement les
difficultés que vous avez soulevé d'une
part une représentation majoritaire de
représentation sous influence étrangère
même si elle est pas totalement négative
à certains égards mais qui en aucun cas
ne contribue à construire un un islam de
de de France et d'autre part il y avait
et il n'y a plus euh je vais dire euh
euh
l'OIF qui effectivement est est plus
composite et plus évolutive qu'on
présente généralementant simplement euh
proche des Frères musulmans mais
j'aurais voulu en savoir plus parce que
si effectivement l'OIF est une
organisation les salafis sont une
nébuleuse est-ce que les Frères
musulmans aussi en tant que tel ne sont
pas une nébuleuse et peuvent recouvrir
des réalités un peu différentes selon
les pays et même à l'intérieur des pays
parce que on présente souvent les Frères
musulmans comme quelque chose de
monoliique et en général de de de euh
d'absolument
incompatible dire avec la laïcité comme
un islam politique et donc qui par
essence serait c'est le problème je
crois quelqu'un a demandé la dissolution
de l'uif à tire alors que c'est
quantitativement aujourd'hui le courant
le le le plus important et le plus
mobilisateur donc j'aurais voulu en
savoir plus là-dessus sur à la fois l'F
et sur la termtique ou non des des des
Frères musulmans sur euh le j'ai été
surpris euh de que vous disiez
effectivement c'est une affaire qui
intérieur et pas extérieur normalement
mais quon mettez en cause le ministère
de l'intérieur parce que le ministère de
l'Intérieur est pas seulement celui de
la police il est celui euh de de des
collectivités locales il est celui de
l'ensemble des des des des affaires
intérieures or si on était au ministère
de la Justice on serait que dans
l'application stricte je veux dire de
règles de droit et non pas justement
quoi je vais pas les poser là mais on
les a toutes les les organisations mais
que ce soit le culte l'abattage rituel
quoi je des des des tas de questions
parfois même à la lisière de
l'enseignement et d'autres euh qui sont
euh ou relèv de l'intérieur ou sont euh
interministériels mais ne peuvent pas
relever d'une approche simplement
strictement euh juridique euh euh et et
et conceptuel euh euh même si
effectivement ça doit pas relever euh
euh des des des des des des Affaires
étrangères alors je n'opposerai pas euh
comme Roger euh je veux dire la fierté
quoi je veux dire il y a aujourd'hui une
dimension internationale du catholicisme
il a une dimension internationale du
judaïsme il y a des dimensions
internationales de toutes religion qui
paraissent C universelle en tout cas
pour les monothéismes qui n'est pas
forcément à opposer au cadre national
mais comme effectivement on est toujours
en quête aujourd'hui et quel serait pour
vous je suis vraiment dans
questionnement même si vous n'avez pas
forcément la réponse de façon absolue on
on a tous les courant de l'islam sauf
les salafistes qui reconnaissent le
besoin de la nécessité de contexte
actualisation posée d'ailleurs dès les
débuts de l'islam or on a aucune
autorité en France reconnue justement
par les musulmans qui peut édicter des
quoi qui peut faire de la
contextualisation depuis la société
française européenne alors c'est pas
même les les sources intellectuel d
modéré d'origine du du Maghreb ou ou du
ou d'Égypte on ne les a pas c'est
parfois la force de Tarik Ramadan qui
qui qui apparaît lui comme parlant
depuis l'Europe euh euh et et passant
relativement bien chez les jeunes si si
euh si j'en juge mais effectivement
quand il parlait de moratoire c'est en
s'adressant à toute la communauté
internationale il pr il proposait pas le
moratoire pour les sociétés européennes
il le proposaent au souiens ou aux
émiratis qui eux jugent cette position
beaucoup trop moderniste justement non
mais beaucoup trop non mais les les les
les les les les états musulm avec lequel
on entretient des relations très
étroites ont une vision de l'islam
infiniment plus concervé atrice
rétrograde la tent droit dehomme que
même celle qui était présentée par Taric
Ramadan et qui était mis en cause àite
par ses nations je crois qu' faut c'est
pas inutile que vous effectivement vous
l'avez rappelé je veux dire à juste
titre mais ça ne répond pas je dire au
au besoins de de efficationation d'une
source intellectuelle de
contextualisation c'est plus difficile
dans un état laïque mais mais mais mais
comment vous voyez les solution pour que
ça ça puisse naître parce que ça manque
toujours en Europe mais mais seulement
un demi-siècle après la véritable
implantation des musulmans alors je suis
un peu surpris euh quand vous dites que
même l'uif ne mort pas chez les jeunes
alors sur quel fait parce qu'on a
l'impression à la limite qu'il y a quee
mais qu'effectivement c'est l'islam euh
organisé depuis euh les les les pays
d'origine qui n'a d'influence que sur la
première génération plus la 2uxè mais
mais déjà plus du tout sur la
3è bien merci pour ces questions euh je
ne suis pas pour qu'on dissolve le CFCM
et peut-être les formulations été brutal
pour mettre en avant quelque chose qui
me semble très important les jeunes je
vais y revenir je voudrais quand même
dire quelque chose sur l'idée que
l'islam ce n'est pas la séparation de
l'Église et de l'État je pense que cette
idée fausse le l'Empire les empires
Byzantins et les empires abassid etomead
l'empires chrétien et les empires ont
fonctionné exactement de la même manière
il n'y a pas quelque chose de spécial
réellement je pense quand on voit
l'histoire il y a pas quelque chose de
spécial et quand vous voyez aujourd'hui
la plupart des sociétés musulmanes
l'essentiel des lois n'a rien à voir
avec l'Islam les entreprises l'armée la
vie quotidienne à part la vie cultuelle
elle ne dépend pas de l'islam jeux dire
il y a une aujourd'hui un retour de
l'idée que la charia est la base de
la de la législation et ça peut avoir
des conséquences négatives notamment sur
la situation des femmes mais c'est
c'estàdire je pense que c'est un peu
simpliste de de de dire finalement la
laïcité c'est nous je rappelle qu'en
1905 quand nous avons accepté quand nous
avons voté la laïcité l'Église
catholique non seulement a été contre
mais qu'elle a mis 40 ans à l'accepter
et que ça n'a pas posé de la problème à
la République on n pas demandé à
l'église catholique comme on a demandé
aux gens qui rentrer dans le CFCM de
signer un texte pour dire qu'ils étaient
pour la laïcité je dis à la limite
aujourd'hui vous pouvez vous avez le
droit d'être contre la laïcité en France
si vous voulez le problème c'est
d'appliquer les lois de la République et
je pense que la majorité des musul
aujourd'hui quelle que soit la manière
dont ils voient la religion ils
appliquent les lois de la République et
c'est ça qui est important et quand les
lois ne sont pas appliquées c'est pour
des raisons qui n'ont rien à voir avec
la religion c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans du point de vue social dans dans un
certain nombre de quartiers donc je
crois que ça c'est quand même quelque
chose de d'important je m'excuse je
voulais dire quelque chose sur les
jeunes que je n'ai pas dit il y a
aujourd'hui je l'ai à peine évoqué une
nouvelle génération de jeunes musulmans
quand je dis musulmans c'est au sens ce
plus large c'est-à-dire qui s'appelle
Mohamed ou Fatima qui sont maintenant
des élus il y en a eu notamment aux
dernières élections municipales il y a
eu une entrée notamment dans les villes
où il y a une forte euh de fortes
communautés et c'est dans d'ailleurs
dans des villes de gauche comme de
droite il y a j'ai dit de nouvelles
génération de gens qui sortent des
universités et c'est ces gens qui sont
l'avenir ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
couper avec le CFCM ou l'if en disant on
veut plus discuter avec vous mais de se
préoccuper de ces gens et pour moi
l'importance de Ramadan c'est justement
c'est un interlocuteur qui est le
représentant de ces jeunes c'est lui en
qui enfin moi j'ai fait des débat avec
lui je veux dire aller n'importe où
aller n'importe où avec enfin je dire
j'ai fait des débats avec lui on a fait
un débat à l'Institut du monde arabe je
sais pas si vous connaissez l'Institut
du monde arabe c'est la salle d'en haut
était pleine il y avait des gens dans
les escaliers ils avaient mis de la
sonorisation dehors on peut penser alors
que que c'est pas alors ce qui serait
intéressant c'est de savoir pourquoi on
refuse de discuter pourquoi nous sommes
le seul pays européen qui refuse de
discuter notre premier ministre refuse
d'aller à une à une réunion européenne
où Tark ramadan est là alors qu'il y a
tous les pays européens ça pose aucun
problème à personne et avoir un débat
avec lui ne veut pas dire accepter tout
ce qu'il dit moi je ne suis moi je suis
en débat avec lui je ne suis pas croyant
j'ai beaucoup de divergence avec lui
mais en quoi il est aujourd'hui une
menace et je dirais que la c'estàd ce
qu'on ne voit pas c'est la menace
essentielle c'est à la fois la menace
qui vient des États qui quand même même
quand ils sont un peu plus modéré nous
exportent des gens qui justement sont
incapables de cont contextualiser quand
on nous envoie des gens d'Algérie des
imams algériens vous savez c'est pas des
imams c'est des gens qui ont eu des
postes par des pots de vin pour pouvoir
venir en France qui sont incapables de
parler au au aux communautés aux
communautés musulmanes c'est ça que nous
voulons je veux dire donc il y a
réellement quelque chose là qui n'est
pas normal allez c'està dire il y a la
question de formation des imams qui
continuent à supposer que ça fait 20 ans
qu'on en parle et nous sommes incapables
de le faire on va envoyer au Maroc les
gens se former mais enfin je veux dire
vraiment je n'arrive pas à comprendre
comment nous qui nous réclamons de la
laïcité de la séparation de l'égliseétat
on peut confier à des États étrangers le
soin de former nos imams je veux dire
c'est quand même là une question donc il
y a un débat à ouvrir avec ces jeunes il
va commencer au niveau local au niveau
local il y a des endroits où ce débat a
lieu mais il reste encore une très
grande méfiance souvent chez les élus
locaux souvent aussi parce que il y a
une une méconnaissance simplement et que
je veux dire quand on a une organisation
dans laquelle il y a des jeunes filles
et qu'une jeune fille porte le foulard
on dit toujours c'est des c'est des
intégristes écoutez moi j'ai travaillé
avec des des des des jeunes filles qui
portent le foulard je peux vous dire
qu'elles sont aussi lib libér celles-là
en tous les cas pas toutes qui sont
aussi libérées elles viennent à des
réunions elles sortent seules le soir
elles n'ont pas la même ell n'ont pas du
tout les mêmes relations que nous nous
avons au aux relations sexuelles ou
amoureuses et cetera mais en dehors de
ça elles veulent travailler elles
veulent elles sont pas prêtes à ce qu'on
choisiss à mari pour eux et cetera mais
s'il y a cette méfiance à l'égard de ces
de ces jeunes il y a un vrai problème je
pense sur ce ce dialogue sur les Frères
musulmans vous avez raison c'est un des
problèmes que nous avons avec l'islam
c'est que on a une vision monolitique
c'est quand on dit l'islamisme moi je
sais pas ce que c'est l'islamisme
franchement je veux dire je c'est les il
y a tellement de courants différents
est-ce que le hzbah c'est la même chose
que les Frères musulmans c'est la même
chose que non c'est pas du tout c'est
des choses très différentes et qui se
battent dans des contextes qui qui
agissent dans des contextes très très
différent donc il y a effectivement chez
les Frères musulmans un débat qu'on a vu
d'ailleurs dans les révolutions arabes
avec les différences qu'il y a eu entre
l'Égypte et la Tunisie avec Égypte une
organisation moi j'ai beaucoup suivi
l'Égypte parce que je connais un peu une
organisation de Frères musulmans
complètement borné vraiment incapable
d'évoluer et de comprendre qu'est-ce que
c'était la politique et en Tunisie une
organisation qui a quand même finalement
avec des luttes je dis pas que c'est
venu spontanément a compris que sil
voulait continuer à peser dans la
société il fallait qu'ils changeent il
fallait qu'ils acceptent de se retirer
du pouvoir et cetera donc ça ça ça
existe et c'est évident que pour les
jeunes générations qui grandissent dans
des pays à majorité non musulmane il y a
des questions nouvelles qui se posent
c'est que vous n'avez pas quand vous
vivez en Égypte je dis en Égypte c'est
le la prière c'est cinq fois par jour
mais les gens sont pas obligés de la
faire je veux dire il y a plein de gens
qui vont pas prier mais c'est la c'est
la vie quotidienne ici il vit dans un
dans une situation minoritaire et ça
c'est il y a tout une réflexion sur la
ce qu'ils appellent la Charira des
minorités la vie dans des minorités
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire vivre dans
des minorités mais dont le principe pour
l'essentiel c'est nous acceptons et
c'est ça c'est un vieux principe de l'
nous acceptons les lois du pays dans
lequel nous sommes alors il y a ça
nempêche pas qu'il y ait des éléments
extrêmement radicaux aussi je veux dire
qu'est-ce des fois je dis aux gens vous
savez l'Église catholique est une église
centralisée avec un pape et vous avez
des gens qui vont de la théologie de la
libération qui prôent la révolution
marxiste à des gens qui sont des
néoconservateurs et ça ne nous étonne
pas et je veux dire c'est
euh qui sont vraiment des je veux dire
il y a une une très
grande une très grande variété je sais
pas si j'ai alors sur
l'international je répète je ne crois
pas que pour un musulman aujourd'hui
même le musulman qui vous dira le Coran
passe avant les lois de la
République
non non je sais non non même un musulman
qui dans sa tête vous dit ou même dans
le débat vous dira le Coran passe pour
moi avant les lois de la République dans
la réalité il applique les lois de la
République après qu'est-ce qu'il veut
qu'est-ce que je veux dire moi ça m'est
égal qu'est-ce qu'il pens dans cette il
y a des catholiques intégristes qui sont
contre l'avortement et ça les empêche
pas de de vivre dans la République il y
a des catholiques intégristes qui sont
contre la laïcité ils vivent dans les
lois de la République il y a des
monarchistes en France ils sont contre
la République on les empêche pas de
vivre je veux dire c'est le la réalité
ce qu'on demande aux musulmans
aujourd'hui c'est d'appliquer les lois
c'est pas même d'être d'accord avec elle
c'est d'appliquer les doigt
voilà d'autres demandes de de parole
madame Keller madame yonet et puisame
Goulet oui merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Monsieur grche Merci pour
votre présentation quelques questions et
peut-être remarque aussi si je peux me
la permettre d'abord vous avez souligné
euh euh les limites de la représentation
du CFCM vous avez fait la comparaison
avec la représentation des Juifs est-ce
que vous avez des propositions pour ma
part je voudrais partager même pour le
la le CFCM euh avec vous l'idée que une
élection proportionnelle au mare carré
c'est quand même un peu frustre pour
s'agissant de personnees hein de de
citoyens qui qui vivent en en France
donc qu'est-ce que vous avez des des
pistes de proposition deuxièmement je
voudrais m'étonner de vos propos de Tari
sur au sujet de tariam c'est bien sûr
une personne extrêmement connue
extrêmement médiatique on connaît le les
débats sur le double langage et et les
le procès qu'il a confronté à Antoine
spher que nous avons eu l'honneur de
d'auditionner la la semaine dernière
donc voilà je je voudrais quand même
m'étonner de vos vos propos je sais bien
que vous avez écrit un livre avec lui
mais je voudrais vous dire que comme
beaucoup d'autres moi je suis
extrêmement impressionné par son
influence alors qu'il n'a pas de
légitimité particulière autre que voilà
sa capacité C son entre gens son euh son
expression et sa capacité à à attirer 3è
question cette fois je voudrais avoir
votre point de vue sur la théorie du
complot tous les ans autour de la date
anniversaire du 11 septembre enfin la
date de commémoration plutôt euh nous
avons dans ma ville des conférences sur
le thème le 11 septembre est un complot
occidental
euh cette idée du complot est de manière
plus plus soft présente quand même
beaucoup sur voilà je suis musulman donc
je suis stigmatisé c'est on le sait les
études l'ont montré vrai sur ce que vous
avez évoqué le CV sur d'autres aspects
c'est parfois instrumentalisé par les
jeunes eux-mêmes créant de ce fait des
des des des fossées qui sont redoutables
qu'est-ce quelle est votre analyse
justement sur cette théorie du complot
qui se développe d'autant plus qu'on est
souvent sur des sitite internet sur des
des fonctionnements un peu voilà plutôt
communautaires plutôt
refermés
enfin là ce sera plutôt une affirmation
vous avez pointé la méfiance des élus
locaux à l'égard de des des des
personnes de confession musulmane je
voudrais dénoncer cela je je ne partage
pas cette vision les maires en
particulier les élus locaux bah ce sont
des citoyens on les croise d'ailleurs
souvent on apprend leur religion plus
tard à l'occasion d'une fête d'Aï enfin
moi je je veux partager ça je je
découvre que des gens avec lesquels je
je bossais parce qu'ils étaient
enseignants patron de PME euh
fonctionnaires de la Ville bah qui sont
ils se trouvêre là au moment de la fête
donc voilà je découvre qu'ils sont
musulmans mais ils sont avant tout voilà
parents d'élèves personne engagées dans
la société donc euh je pense qu'il faut
vraiment pas partir de ce cet a priori
et je si je peux me permettre plutôt
creuser la piste que vous avez indiquer
il y a des élus municipaux parce que
c'est voilà c'est la réalité de la
représentation de la diversité qui dans
les équipes municipales ne représentent
pas leur communauté mais sont là pour
participer en tant que citoyen de plein
exercice
euh dans euh voilà dans l'ensemble des
des thématiques de de la collectivité je
pense qu'il y a là plutôt un élément
d'espoir que enfin je vous propose de
d'adoucir votre paradigme et de de de
penser que peut-être les élus sont un
une connaissance comme mes collègues
l'ont prouvé aussi de voilà de la cette
réalité dans leur territoire je vous
remercie il y a eu déjà beaucoup de de
choses dites vous remercier pour votre
exposé euh dire deux trois choses dans
alors c'est peut-être dans votre façon
de parler j'ai trouvé que vous aviez un
peu banalisé le port du voile qui a fait
un débat national quand même et qui a
posé certains problèmes et qui pose des
problèmes notamment quand on est
fonctionnaire de la République et qu'on
ne doit pas porter le voile par exemple
et donc dans des villes comme comme les
nôtres où il y a beaucoup de de cités il
y a beaucoup de choses qui se disent sur
effectivement des femmes qui sont
voilées et qui vont chercher leurs
enfants à l'école donc je je pense que
on peut pas banaliser ce genre de choses
parce que elles sont réelles et on
s'aperçoit que par exemple sur le 93 on
a de plus en plus de femmes voilées et y
compris qui porte la la bourka et qui
qui qui pose un un vrai problème de fond
alors respect pour ces femmes he c'est
leur choix j'ai bien compris leur
démarche mais en tout cas ça pose un
problème pour le pour la République en
ce qui concerne des élus oui la la
diversité de
de de chaque ville fait que aujourd'hui
nous avons des
élus qui représente la diversité des
territoires alors moi je je rejoins
madame dans ce qu'elle dit bien sûr
certains représentent la République et
en sont très fiers mais on a quelques
mauvais souvenirs ou des des euh des
élus de la diversité sont venus par
exemple en boubou ou avec les youyou ou
avec des choses comme ça et dans on a eu
le sentiment un petit peu de
de voilà que
le
ça y est merci et donc c'est vrai que on
n pas une tendance à banalisé et
d'ailleurs on a bien vu avec la montée
du du Front national ce que ça pouvait
donner alors il y
a je suis un petit peu obligé de de le
dire quand même euh pour avoir fait
beaucoup de permanence en tant
qu'élu de ma ville j'ai rencontré
beaucoup
de de femmes euh qui parlaient de la
religion et qui euh notamment se trouve
confronté à la polygamie alors que la
polygamie en France est interdite quel
est le modèle aussi
d'intégration pour ces femmes qui se
retrouvent du jour au lendemain avec
cinq enfants qu'on est obligé de
divorcer de maquiller pour qu'elle
puisse toucher leur allocation et avoir
et avoir un logement tout simplement
pour élever les enfants donc la
République c'est c'est c'est vaste mais
ça par exemple moi je je n'ai pas su
répondre si ce n'est faire les papiers
pour qu'elle puisse divorcer et être
prise en charge sur les jeunes des cités
vous l'avez dit dans la première
audition que nous avons eu nous avons eu
un représentant de l'État sur la
foress ça je vous garantis que c'est pas
moi qui les casse je sais pas si je vais
film avec autant de micro mais bon allez
on continue pour les jeunes des cités
qui est ma plus grande inquiétude quand
même que je rencontre régulièrement
euh il y a un véritable souci avec les
imams vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure les
imams qui s'improvisent un peu comme ça
qui arrivent dans de ses dou et qui vont
faire qui vont prêcher la bonne la bonne
parole et qui pose souvent des beaucoup
de problèmes et euh le sentiment qui
viennent dansen nous citer pour
justement voir ces jeunes qui comme on
dit tiennent un peu les murs donc quand
on discute de leur avenir c'est pas les
lois de la République qui les
intéressent au premier abord euh c'est
j'ai pas de travail j'ai pas de logement
euh je suis en échec scolaire comment je
je vais faire pour m'en sortir et alors
c'est là où les lois de la République
devrai intervenir c'est ces imams qui
les orientent d'une autre façon euh
plutôt que dans dans la religion mais
qui
euh qui les radicalise et qui pose un
problème quand même de fond parce que
moi ces jeunes que j'ai vu grandir dans
la cité euh aujourd'hui qui ont 20 25
ans qui tiennent toujours les murs
euh on a senti la radicalisation de ces
jeunes et qui a été faite par des imams
voilà donc je vous passe le détail alors
quand comment régler tous ces problèmes
comment les valeurs de la République
dans cette religion peuvent être
comprise euh ils les connaissent pas ils
ont pas l'impression vous l'avez dit
qu'ils sont Français à part entière mais
là c'est un peu quand même de notre
faute je l'ai dit la dernière fois mais
je le redis euh première génération 2e
génération issue de euh fils de
immigration et cetera donc comment euh
lier cette cette religion aux valeurs de
la République alors que nous sommes des
laïques pour la plupart comment comment
le lier et quel place peuvent-ils
trouver et je je voudrais bien une
réponse là-dessus ces jeunes perdus
aujourd'hui quelle perspective pour eux
et qu'est-ce que peut représenter la
République sans qu'ils connaissent
l'histoire vraiment de la République et
qui s désintéresse parce que c'est pas
c'est pas leur
objectif je casse plus de micro je le
rends alors je vous propose de prendre
encore deux questions parce que le temps
passe pour pouvoir donner ensuite la
parole à Monsieur grche donc je vais
madame Durieux et Monsieur
mou oui merci madame la Présidente ben
je serai relativement brève parce que
j'allis poser les les mêmes questions et
je voulais d'abord vous remercier
Monsieur
grche je pense
que les jeunes les jeunes en tout cas en
France ont probablement besoin
d'apprendre l'islam je sais pas lequel
hein et d'apprendre l'islam bon à partir
de là il y a deux choses qui sont
probablement dangereuses c'est
qu'apparemment on peut être imam en
sautoproclamant imam j'aimerais bien que
vous nous précisiez effectivement
comment ces choses-là pe se
peuvent-elles se faire et quelle
crédibilité accorde- ton dans la
hiérarchie des imams bon deuxièmement la
formation sera essentielle enfin ça
c'est votre affaire et euh je dirais que
nous sommes un État laïque et quelque
part que vous déploriez qu'il soit formé
en Algérie au Maroc en Turquie peut-être
mais enfin pourquoi sont-ils donc pas
formés en France si vous préfériez cela
et quand vous évoquez la Turquie j'ai
envie de dire que dans un état Laï Dogan
a tranché il a créé les écoles
imamatiques et en les forme dans les
écoles laïques de l'État turc c'est pas
une solution pour la France alors ces
problèmesl me paraissent essentiels ceux
qui tournent autour des imam
oui une question très courte vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que les musulmans
respectaient les lois de la
République comme les catholiques même
s'ils étaient pas toujours d'accord avec
ma collègue a parlé de la polygamie donc
on peut douter qu'il les RESPE toutes
mais la question est la suivante est-ce
que vous pensez que il y a une démarche
de l'islam pour que soit prise en compte
précisément euh les valeurs de l'Islam
si tenter qu'on puisse parler de valeur
enfin bon moi je vais dire ça comme ça
parce que dans les lois de la
République disons que les catholiques
ont pesé
et d'une manière forte hein simplement
prenant un exemple les vacances
scolaires correspondent aux dates
principales voilà donc c'est le sens de
ma
question monsieur grche vous laisse bon
il y a il y a beaucoup de questions il y
a des questions qui concernent la
laïcité euh moi je suis un fervant
partisan de la laïcité de la laïcité de
la loi de 1905 pas de celle qu'on essaie
de d'interpréter de manière différente
aujourd'hui la laïcité c'est la
neutralité de la République c'est pas la
neutralité des citoyens qu'une femme
porte le foulard ça me pose aucun
problème je dire si et je dirais non
seulement ça ne me pose aucun problème
mais je vous interroge en tant que moi
qui me prétend féministe je fréquente
ces femmes qui portent le foulard et qui
savent qu'il n qu'elles n'ont aucune
chance de trouver un travail alors que
normalement c'est légal à part pour être
fonctionnaire de travailler en ayant le
foulard tellement elles sont
stigmatisées donc il y a effectivement
moi je n'ai pas de problème avec le
foulard je je côtois des gens qui
s'habillent de manière très différente
j'en ai rien à faire c'est pas mon
problème c'est le problème des des choix
de ces genes du moment que c'est un
choix libre je veux dire je suis pas
pour imposer le foulard ni pour imposer
que oui mais après vous dites il y a la
pression sociale mais vous croyez que
dans nos milieux il n'y a pas de
pression sociale sur toute la vie
quotidienne la nôtre sur les mariages
sur la vie sociale enfin je veux dire
vous vivez où il y a une pression
sociale qui s'exerce elle peut être plus
ou moins forte elle est plus forte dans
les ghettos et le problème c'est de
s'interroger pourquoi il y a des ghettos
et là je dirais et ça c'est pas la faute
des musulmans je veux dire s'il y a un
problème de la République et vous
quelqu'un a dit ce n'est pas les lois
des républiques qui les intéressent et
je crois que c'est tout à fait vrai ce
qui les intéresse c'est de trouver du
travail moi j'ai été faire un débat
après Charlie dans un un un un lycée
professionnel de jeunes de 14 16 ans on
a discuté pendant 3h c'était passionnant
il savent pas écrire ils sont les ils
sont nés en France ils ont fait l'école
de la République non seulement ils ne
savent pas ils ne connaissent pas
l'orthographe avant la réforme mais ils
connaissent ils ne savent même pas
s'exprimer et ils sont ils savent qu'ils
vont être chômeurs franchement la
laïcité c'est pas un problème pour eux
ni pour ni contre ils savent même pas ce
que c'est c'est pas en en en disant nous
allons faire des cours de laïcité que
nous allons convaincre qui que ce soit
c'est c'est une
plaisanterie d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui de plus en plus la
laïcité apparaît comme une machine de
guerre contre les musulmans et puisque
les signes religieux nous choquent tant
je vous rappelle quand même dans cette
noble assemblée que jusque dans les
années 60 nous avons eu des prêtres élus
qui venaient en soutane ici sans que ça
pose le moindre problème la le ch kir
venit en soutane bon qu'est-ce que c'est
vous imaginez aujourd'hui une une élu
venant en avec un foulard d'ailleurs je
vous signale pour je crois que c'est la
ville il y a une ville il y a une ville
qui vient de basculer de du de c'est
bobini
ou non non non pas Auberville qui vient
parer du Parti communiste à l'UDI dans
Sani non mais bobini bobini sur la liste
de l'UDI il y avait deux filles qui
portent le foulard ça né aucun problème
pourquoi brusquement ça devient une une
question
importante je veux dire même la droite
aujourd'hui reconnaît que je veux dire
c'est c'est la le libre choix des c'est
le libre choix des gens et encore une
fois les mesures que nous prenons contre
les femmes qui portent le foulard c'est
des mesures contre les femmes c'est pas
les hommes qui sont visés c'est c'est à
elle qu'on interdit d'accompagner leurs
enfants c'est à elle qu'on interdit
accéder au travail bon euh sur bien sûr
il y a la la question de la polygamie la
polygamie je vous signale
essentiellement c'est sur l'Afrique
c'est pas dans les pays arabes bon des
pays musulmans ou d'ailleurs non
musulmans d'Afrique il y a un vrai
problème mais on a un problème
d'intégration bien sûr je veux dire
c'est pas personne ne dit qu'il faut
mais on sait très bien que le rés c'est
pas très facile à résoudre si on veut
tenir compte de l'intérêt des femmes
comme vous dites quand quand une femme
se retrouve dans une situation de
polygamie c'est pas elle qu'on va punir
IR on va essayer de trouver une solution
qui est d'une certaine manière un
détournement autre chose sur la la
République laïque en
1926 en
1926 l'Assemblée nationale française a
financé la construction de la Mosquée de
Paris la mairie de Paris a donné 500000
francs à l'époque pour le terrain
c'était contraire à la laïcité
complètement et Brian qui était le
rapporteur à lacité qu'est-ce qu'il a
dit il a dit oui c'est normal parce que
il y a rattrapage à faire après tout
tous les édifices du culte sont
entretenus par les par nos impôts nos
impôts de citoyens qui ont peut-être
rien à voir avec la religion mais ça ça
ne nous choque pas
oui y compris musulman mais je ne sais
pas je suis pas pour dire qu'il faut
construire des des des mosquées payé je
dis simplement que la vision euh de la
laïcité des fondateurs de la laïcité
c'était une vision d'une laïcité qui
permettait l'exercice du culte je vous
rappelle aussi que les premières après
la loi de
1905 125 maires ont décidé d'interdire
les processions religieuses dans la rue
en disant que c'était contraire à à à la
laïité dans 121 cas ça a été cassé par
le Conseil
d'État je veux dire ça non mais mais si
c'est important l'espace l'espace la rue
et la la rue est à je veux dire on a le
droit d'exprimer sa religion dans la rue
ce
que non mais on pas pard
excusez-moi s'il vous plaît un peu sur
la forme là parce que l'heure est passée
et on n'interpelle pas notre invité
comme ça parce que sinon il ne pourra
pas répondre sachant que on va devoir
conclure rapidement et que la rapporteur
dire un mot aussi sur l'affaire je vais
pas rentrer sur l'affaire Tarek Ramadan
Antoine spher moi j'ai témoigné et je
peux vous dire qu'Antoine spher mentait
sur tare Ramadan je veux pas rentrer
là-dedans mais ce que je vous demande
c'est de l'écouter d'écouter ce qu'ils
disent
pardon non non non mais écoutez je
faites un débat avec Ramadan je dirais
même s'il y a des choses qui disent que
vous n'êtes pas d'accord si vous
reconnaissez que aujourd'hui il
représente pourquoi il représent les
jeunes musulmans je vais vous dire moi
pourquoi ils représentent les jeunes
musulmans c'est justement il représent
ces jeunes dont j'ai parlé c'est-à-dire
quelqu'un dont il sont fiers parce qu'il
parlent bien et parce qu'il il a ils ont
l'impression qu'il est un vrai musulman
et qu'il ne tient pas le discours de
certains intellectuels musulmans que
nous sommes très contents de voir à la
télévision parce qu'ils disent
exactement ce que nous nous avons envie
d'entendre
voilà sur la la question de la théorie
du complot et de la victimisation des
jeunes c'est tout à fait vrai
c'està-dire il y a de vraies théories du
complot qui se développent c'est pas
seulement dans les communautés
musulmanes sur le 11 septembre il y a eu
des personnes célèbres qui ont dit mais
le 11 septembre n'a jamais eu lieu
c'était des des Français de enfin de
souche ou non donc il y a il y a
effectivement c'est un phénomène
compliqué parce que il touche la société
avec la méfiance à l'ég à l'égard des
politiques et à l'égard des médias qui
favorise cette chose et touche
particulièrement les communautés
musulmanes et il faut combattre bien sûr
c'est quelque chose de de de très de
très dangereux
euh juste encore
euh l'idée que la Turquie est laïque
c'est vraiment une idée je dis je sais
pas d'où elle sort il y a un ministère
des Cultes qui nomme les imams je je ne
sais pas si c'est ça si c'est ça la
laïité pardon non non elle na pas été
elle n'a jamais été çaà dire quoi laïque
vous imaginez un pays laïque dans lequel
il y a un ministère des Cultes qui nomme
les imams et ça c'était vrai sous
ataturque c'est pas Erdogan ça a
toujours été comme ça les les les imams
qu' exportent ici ça vient des des des
et du ministère des Cultes bon enfin bon
ça c'est un autre la question des imames
elle est très compliquée parce que
effectivement il y a pas de de de il y a
des formations notamment qu'on fait mais
il y a pas de titre officiel c'est le
fait d'être reconnu plus ou moins par
mais il y a il y a un effort à faire je
ne sais pas
lequel je sais que ça fait 20 ans qu'on
en discute on avait pensé de faire une
vous savez à Strasbourg de faire une
chose je pense qu'il faut prendre le il
faut le il faut le faire parce que c'est
quelque chose qui me semble euh
important la dernière chose c'est sur
les propositions pour le pour le CS le
CFCM
euh je termine sur le CFCM on a pas
tellement le temps c'est extrêmement
compliqué mais pour une raison qui est
simple c'estàdire s'il avait fallu
aujourd'hui organiser le conshistoire
Juif on aurait pas on serait la
République n'aurait pas réussi à le
faire aujourd'hui elle a pu le faire en
1804 parce que Bonaparte pouvait dire
n'importe quoi il il il l'appliquit là
on a un vrai un vrai problème donc je
n'ai pas de de de
solution je suis de ceux qui pensent que
bon faisons avec le CFCM puisque ça ça
existe parce que ça a permis notamment
la nomination des des des homoniers dans
un certain nombre de de lieux clos mais
prenons en compte le fait qu'ils ne sont
pas l'avenir des musulmans de France et
que cet avenir des musulmans de France
il faut le bâtir avec ces jeunes qui
sont effectivement dans dans les
municipalités j'ai pas voulu dire
excusez-moi si je l'ai je l'ai dit sur À
propos des élus il y a un certain nombre
de ville où il y a des méfiances c'est
pas le fait que quand quand un élu voit
un musulman il s'enfuit c'est quand il y
a une organisation musulmane qui est sur
place il y a euh parce que et c'est je
veux dire c'est c'est pas un reproche je
le comprends c'est des c'est des
pratiques qui nous sont en partie
étrangèr c'est une fois qui nous est en
partie étrangère donc il y a un effort à
faire pour ouvrir le le dialogue mais il
y a a un effort à faire aussi par ces
organisations elles-mêmes qui
elles-mêmes sont dans une posture de
victimisation et si pour terminer je
dois rendre hommage à tar Ramadan pour
une chose c'est le fait qu'il n'arrête
pas de dénoncer la le
l'auto le discours de victimisation que
tiennent que qu'ont les musulmans en
France
voilà alors comme j'ai la chance de de
travailler régulièrement avec Alain
grche j'ai laissé mes collègues mais
j'ai quand même j'ai quand même une
observation et une très courte question
l'observation c'est que globalement ce
qui a été dit aujourd'hui recoupe tout à
fait clairement ce qu' a dit barizakari
la semaine dernière
c'est-à-dire moi je suis représenté à la
télévision par des analphabète et pas
par des gens que j'ai envie d'entendre
elle elle a elle a plusieurs fois
considéré
elle a dit elle a dit ça plusieurs
fois non mais elle a pas dit la tél
télévision elle a dit qu quand j'entends
elle a pas parlé du président du CFCM
Roger carucci elle a pas parlé de ça
elle a dit que la représentation ne lui
ressemblait pas elle l'a dit plusieurs
fois la semaine dernière donc on est
dans un aussi dans un problème de
représentation la deuxième chose mais
j'ai quand même une j'ai quand même une
question sur les influences étrangères
parce que on a parlé du lien avec les
ambassades étrangères en France et moi
je voudrais votre avis monsieur grche
sur les financements étrangers
je pense que d'une certaine manière ces
financements sont euh comment dire très
difficile à à situer et à mesurer
c'est-à-dire que
euh comme souvent ce n'est pas des
financement il y a des financements
directement étatiques ça c'est
relativement facile mais ensuite ça se
fait à travers des réseaux musulmans
croyants qui sont du golf ou de tel ou
tel pays qui sont relativement puissant
et qui peuvent apporter beaucoup
d'argent je pense qu'en parti il y a un
fantasme aussi sur les sur cette sur ce
financement mais je pense que ça vaut la
peine justement d'étudier au cas par cas
c'est-à-dire d'avoir une discussion
approfondie et de réfléchir sur comment
effectivement avoir un contrôle des
financements encore que c'est pas
illégal d'avoir un financement étranger
hein je veux dire c'est je je sais pas
si l'Église de France est oui il faut
qu'il soit il faut qu'il soit
transparent mais peut-être là c'est
alors c'est je ne sais pas si c'est
possible à imaginer
que d'une manière ou d'une autre les
associations
de les associations musulmanes locales
il ait d'une manière ou d'une autre une
une représentation d'élu je sais pas de
créer des associations spéciales si je
vouis dire qui qui pourrai contrôler par
exemple je sais pas si c'est si c'est
envisageable ou non ou trouver donc sans
que ça soit une mamie ça peut être une
fondation pour les voilà il y avait la
Fondation pour les de l de France mais
la voix oui oui il y a toujours elle
fonctionne pas mais peut-être localement
d'essayer de réfléchir à ce type de de
formule qui aussi d'une certaine manière
permettrait parce que on sait très bien
que les communautés musulmanes
localement même elles sont extrêmement
divisées qu'il y a des il y a des des
Lutes entre elles qui a des des des
factions et cetera peut-être ça
permettrait aussi une forme de présence
mais encore une fois je demande pas que
le le les les les élus s'occupent de de
la mosquée mais qui ait une forme de
présence qui permettrait des
associations loi peut-être 1901 d'avoir
une forme de contrôle là-dessus toute
façon en principe les les les les les
mosquées doivent avoir des comptes
ouverts
quoi aux États-Unis c'est comme ça les
fondations ont un un officier public
enfin un comptable
public un membre de l'administration du
Trésor qui est dans les fondations merci
merci
infiniment voilà pour cette matinée
consacrée au travaux du Sénat notamment
aux travaux de la mission d'information
sur la place de l'islam en France une
mission d'information qui a commencer à
travailler au début du mois de janvier
sur cette thématique avec audition et
déplacement une mission d'information
qui a été créée à l'initiative du groupe
centriste vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir tous les travaux du Sénat sur
notre site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 pour Sénat 360 présenté par
Delphine Gérard très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires